hello and welcome to this video let's do
something else get the more again but
you know I'm hesitating simply because I
don't quite know what I want to play
and I think this is a line that right
here
okay so should be three or this is the
thing
can I go here this is something that he
has to keep in mind the pin okay I feel
like it feels a little bit like everyday
I'm in danger here if he moves to have
to do it anyway
if he moves the bishop back there is
Knight b6
yeah that's developed come on get pieces
out yeah in a position like that what
definitely has compensation I mean I'm
not sure if I'm worse was or if it's
just like okay for why they're not not
I'm not able to say that so easily
hmm okay oh wait if I take the five toin
takes Bishop g5 is that good friend
hmm
came Bishop tanks the night is hanging
you know when g5
I don't see don't see anything
particularly threatening
yeah
he has some so extremely active pieces
so it is definitely some sort of
compensation yeah Bishop f4 maybe
staying active with this
I will go f5 and some cases here
definitely but first of all let's see if
I can get rid of this one this bishop
it didn't make much sense now with
hindsight f5 there's g3 okay
it's got Bishop c5 that's something that
he probably should have thought about
let's see
counter-attack no Queen trade
no Queen trade please 13 seconds 13
seconds
maybe I could have taken on g3 then
going for III age six is hanging but II
to is also a threat pretty big threat
and I don't see how I don't see a movie
FM ito is such a huge threat
the question is of Queen age three is
winning now I don't really I want to
find out
if he trades Bishop is hanging
not easy now with 10 seconds on the
clock even though I'm his king position
is quite quite an issue so check him how
do I get there though how do I get there
now justice
should be true doesn't do it's okay I'm
damn it
[Music]
was that necessary
I don't know keeping that can take on
edge for even next smooth right you made
it god damn it I should never do that no
just any move wins come on I was so
shocked yeah I can't even take I can't
even take losing this is so awful yeah
this happens I mean I I rarely do
sometime and increment blitz but
sometimes doom yeah so I had made so hit
mates admits I just frigging I am anyway
so we had this opening here and I don't
know it to be honest
really five is it bad the end and gives
what slight advantage but not that it's
not a really it's no depth really
they're 22 and the way it turned out he
had a pretty substantial compensation
that didn't feel right for me
and so I did I don't believe that one
take Tina coops Bishop takes engine
wants to take with the bishop yeah I
mean this is possible and it's it
strategically quite desirable to do that
it's it's quite close now
but you have to untangle this position
so this isn't so great interesting Luke
takes okay Luke takes and the engine
gives wide enough compensation for the
two points yeah there's Bishop c5 again
I didn't like my position to begin with
it's just a cheap spacer around here it
must be quite clearly better foot but
for black of course but couldn't quite
couldn't quite find the right way to do
it and here he allowed me this attack by
simply pushing the f-pawn yeah F takes
what's winning
okay you have to click here I should I
should just winner I have to allow that
one okay that's easy actually right this
is very easy just this and there is no
check let's go check it all just mate
okay I mean this is winning as well
Queen h3 yeah Queen f3 is a very clean
win because now I have Luke d8 and you
have no move it was this isn't even the
best but okay I had no time I was
playing on the increment of all time and
then he killed himself was g4 which was
entirely unnecessary I mean here here
white is okay and g4 is just a suicidal
move which is completely useless to do
yeah basically anything wins so this is
easy
yes but I wanted to play king g6 simply
and then also wins of course g4 was
suicidal yeah but okay if you write on
the incremental time it can get to you
oh okay guys thanks for watching